Nationally, what did this survey show?
What are the kinds of preferences people are coming up?
If the election was happening today,
how would they vote? They would vote the a N C out of power.
Um, we've seen this in other polls as well.
I think that what it shows if we look at a N C support first,
a precipitous fall in the N C
support from 57% in 2019 to only 41% today.
Um, that is an enormous number.
When we are going to look at it,
we will see.
What happened is that much of the Zulu vote has abandoned the ANC
for MK and that they've also lost support to other parties.
So there would be voted out of majority as a majority government
and there is likely therefore to drop to 41.4%.
Yes, perfect.
How do you interpret that? Yes.
Yes. I think the phrasing here is very important indeed.
Vote them out of majority power.
But the a N C
by far second biggest party in this ranking here is the d a.
On half the support that a N C has, 41%,
20% here to the d a,
which means if one has to form a majority government
and the Constitution says government is formed by majority,
there is a big chance that a N C will be in power,
but in coalition relationships with other parties.
So it would remain. And of course,
the result had
it looks like the preference Here it would remain at 41.4%
the dominant party. Doctor Mkabe.
Yes, then I think this is very important.
Um, in a sense that I mean,
all the service, all the polls, uh,
they vary in terms of the methodology
in terms of the margin of error and all of that,
but they all predict the same thing or not prediction we,
we want, but they all state the same opinion,
which is that the a N C will remain a dominant factor
whether it comes down below 50% er or not,
it remains a dominant factor.
Majority of South Africans still prefer the a N C
even though its support is.